Okay.
[Applause]
Bible.
foreign.
Thank you. Uh the sister's name is
Sister Kitara. She's a teacher and um
she said uh from hearing your talk uh we
know that if we want to know about a
religion we should read its scriptures.
So she says she has watched a lot of
videos and read Bible from the book of
uh from the acts of apostles
uh chapter 11 uh until verse until
chapter 26 chapter 11 verse 25- 26 uh
where it is mentioned that uh the
Christianity the teachings some of them
are from God and some of them are from
uh Paul. So she wants to know how could
we differentiate when we are reading
Bible which verse is from God and which
verse is from
>> men.
>> The sister has asked a good question
that she's a teacher and she's asking
that we know that in the Bible there are
some words which are of God and some
words which are of men like Paul etc.
>> Yes.
>> So how can we come to know which part of
the Bible is from God and which part is
from men? That's a very good question.
Number one, if you have heard my talks,
Allah says in the Quran in surah ro
chapter number 13:38, Allah says,
"In every age have we sent a message, a
revelation by name only four are
mentioned. Torah, zab, and the Quran."
Torah is the revelation which was given
to Moses peace be upon him. Zabur is the
revelation which was given to David
peace be upon him. Inj is the revelation
which was given to Jesus Christ peace be
upon him. And Quran is the last and
final revelation given to the last and
final messenger prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him. Now all the revelation that
came before before or before the last
and final revelation the glorious Quran
was only meant for those people and for
a particular time period like Musa
Alisam and Isaam came only for Bunnings
is the message was meant for a
particular time period not for eternity.
So today if I'm doing research I can do
academic research to know what is what
but I have to follow the last and final
message that is a glorious Quran. Now
you ask me the question how will I come
to know what portion of the Bible is
from God and what is from human being.
Quran the another name of Quran is furan
criteria to judge right from wrong. So
whatever matches with the Quran we
Muslims have no objection in agreeing it
may be the word of God.
What goes against the Quran we say it is
not the word of God. What is neither
against neither for ambiguous we are
silent. So the rule is if it matches
with the Quran we have no objection or
matches with the say hadith we have no
objection accepting that p that part as
god like how I quoted in the book of
deuteronomy chapter number 6 verse
number four mus alisam says shama is
your oh Israel the lord our god is one
god same thing was said by Jesus Christ
peace be upon him in the gospel of mark
12:29 so this is matching with the Quran
so we have no objection in agreeing that
is the word of god What is against?
If it goes something against
the Quran, we take objection.
Like some people claim that Jesus said
he's God. He never said that. So they
try and pick up some verses. It cannot
be. It's against the vers of the Quran.
What doesn't go against the Quran nor is
agreeing with the Quran. It's ambiguous.
We are silent on that.
But
if you are doing for academic purpose,
it's good. If you are doing for haya,
you only have to follow the Quran. Even
if you come to know that was the word of
God, you don't have to follow it because
that was meant for those people in that
time. Even if you come to know this
portion of the Bible is from God, this
is not from God. It may not for dava
purpose. Yes. To do dawa to the
Christian good, but for our dad, Quran
is sufficient. Hope that answers the
question.